this is just a reminder for men that  scientists have now discovered a way for  women to impregnate themselves using  their own bone marrow and the only child  that can result from those pregnancies  are female  so we no longer have any need for you  genetically or physically so you know  tread lightly um that  is not true  at all that's not even a little true  it's false no way not this time so put  down the mascara honey and use your  brain for a minute  if you have one you actually think that  women can impregnate themselves  and that isn't a big deal to you besides  if you don't need no man as you suggest  then i sure hope you don't expect men  to pay for your meals when you go out on  a date  i hope when that check comes you're  reaching for it every single time but as  we know classic thing we've i i have  never heard of a feminist who remains a  feminist when the check hits the table  doesn't that doesn't work does it